good afternoon everyone I am really glad
to see you here for the lunchtime
session of this important conference i'm
sure you all had a wonderfully
stimulating morning i had my own
stimulating morning as some of my
students here can attest we were
discussing miranda but i'm sure you all
had a lot more fun than we did I'm here
to introduce to you professor Lani
Guinier sitting right here who is the
Bennett bosque professor of law at
Harvard Law School professor guinier is
actually a graduate of this University's
law school and after leaving Yale
professor Guinier practice as a civil
rights attorney at the United States
Department of Justice Civil Rights
Division and then at the end of a CP
Legal Defense Fund after several years
in practice professor guinier then
headed to the University of Pennsylvania
law school where she began deeply
thoughtful and path-breaking scholarly
work focused on issues of race gender
inequality and methods of structuring
and restructuring Democratic decision
making in order to address the
distortive effects on citizenship that
race gender and class inequality can
have professor granero has published a
host of books including becoming
gentlemen women law school and
institutional change with Michelle fine
and Jane bailon the monata miners canary
and listing race resisting power
transforming democracy with gerald
Torres and published just last month the
tyranny of the meritocracy democratizing
higher education in America in addition
to all this professor wanneer is a
talented and inspirational teacher
having won many awards for her teaching
we here are proud and lucky to have had
her teach at Yale Law School and hopeful
she will come again and I can say
personally Lonnie is a wonderful friend
and mentor and an inspiration to those
of us women
and everyone but I'm speaking personally
women of color and law eating but now it
is time for us to learn again from
Professor Kinnear
so I have at least five different
speeches that I could use to talk to you
today but I think it's most important
especially having experienced the first
half of our convening or the first i
should say the morning of our convening
that what really strikes me about being
back at Yale Law School is the
importance of developing a learning
environment in which participants can
develop and build on relationships among
diverse groups of people who come from
different backgrounds in order to work
together to solve problems now why did I
pick that particular topic because one
of the things that makes me happy to
come back to New Haven is that my son
went here as an undergraduate I went to
the law school and I've then also been
invited to come back and teach at the
law school and one of the themes that I
think is really trapped in those
different experiences is the importance
of being able to work together not only
with your peers but with your students
to solve problems and the particular
form of problem solving that I want to
talk about because I think it's really
important especially in the context of
this forum in which we're trying to talk
about the voting rights act and talk
about democracy in a claimed to be
democratic society and in that process
how do we talk in a way that's not just
about grieving or complaining but is
really about solving problems that is
about brainstorming collectively
solutions or at least as espera
two solutions that may work better than
what the status quo is providing and so
this collaborative problem-solving idea
is what I call confirmative mette-marit
in that it rejects the idea of
individual competition in pursuit or
based on individual merit so when you
think for example about people applying
to Yale Law School of people applying to
Yale College the conversation tends to
be very individualistic it's about each
person trying very hard to get the
special prize and what I'd like us to
step back and think about is the
importance of developing identifying and
working with a diverse group of people
who have very different perspectives but
can work together to collaborate to
solve really challenging problems so I'm
choosing this particular theme in part
because I just wrote a book about it the
tyranny of the meritocracy so I'm really
interested in your feedback in terms of
the thesis of that book because it just
was published and so I don't know if
it's a good book or a bad book I'm
really interested in in your feedback so
some of the things that inspired me to
focus on this problem of collaborative
problem-solving and I shouldn't say this
problem of collaborative problem solving
but this opportunity to consider
collaborative problem-solving as a means
of not only changing the world but of
educating a population so I was inspired
in part by a professor of calculus which
may seem very strange since I know very
little about math but his name is or eat
Reisman at the time that I'm going to
reference he was a graduate student at
Berkeley he's now a professor at
ut University of Texas Austin and he was
concerned because he was teaching
calculus and the black students in his
class we're not doing as well as some of
the other students and he wanted to to
know what the problem was and he talked
to his colleagues about why you know the
black students weren't doing very well
and his colleagues came back with I
guess you'd have to call it predictable
responses in the United States which is
there must be something wrong with those
black people they're probably not
working very hard they're not doing
their homework it's you know all their
fault well to Murray tries means better
half he said well let me see what
they're doing any hired people to
actually videotape what the black
students were doing when they were
studying calculus and then he also
noticed that the Chinese American
students were doing really well in
calculus so he had somebody tape video
taped them and he discovered that the
black students were studying calculus
but they were doing it alone they were
sitting in their dorm rooms with the
calculus book open and trying to work
through the problems the Chinese
American students were talking calculus
with each other when they were walking
to class when they were eating lunch
when they were eating dinner and it was
that ability to work in a group and to
get other people to help you understand
points of challenge that struck tries
men's attention and he then arranged a
and opportunity for the black students
to meet in a separate a quote-unquote
posse on a separate group and talk about
various calculus problems together and
through that process the black students
scores in calculus started to go up now
he also served food that is important
but the food was not because the black
students were too thin or needed to gain
weight it was because people were more
relaxed in talking to each other while
they were eating and they didn't feel as
if there was a competitive sort of
architecture where they were competing
against each other they were working
together to solve these problems now or
eat Reisman is not the only professor
that I've talked to about changing the
way in which we think about merit to
think about it as something that is the
outcome of collaborative and engaged
interaction as opposed to a merit being
measured by how well you do on the s80
the LSA T the GRE or whatever other
tests you took to get here and i have to
say especially with regard to the LSA t
when i was at the university of
pennsylvania law school for reasons that
i'm not yet clear on the Dean gave me
access to four years of grades at the
University of Pennsylvania law school
now that's unusual but he also gave me
their the people's LSA t-scores their
undergraduate GPA all of this I was
doing twenty odd years ago but that was
about women not about issues of race but
it has some overlap because part of what
i found looking at the data on women and
men at the university of pennsylvania
law school the women and the men had
very similar LSA t-scores very similar
undergraduate GPA s but once they got to
law school the men were more likely to
rise to the top of the class and the
women to the bottom of the class and
nobody seemed to care right nobody
seemed to think there must be something
wrong with the tests were using or the
atmosphere that we're creating that
women who had very similar LSA t-scores
very similar undergraduate GPAs we're
not doing as well once they got to law
school
now what what Eric moszer did in try to
figure out what's going on he's the the
professor of physics he was also worried
because in his physics class the women
were not doing as well as the men and so
he decided that he was going to give the
students an opportunity to talk to each
other on particular issues that that
some students found difficult and so he
gave everybody clickers and he gave them
questions and you had to click the
answer and then talk to your peers who
were sitting next to you or sitting in
front of you about the answer you chose
and then after talking to your peers you
get a second chance of zapping the
zapping of what the right answer is and
it he found that that also worked very
well to improve the women's performance
in physics that is once they had a
physics test they really understood the
concepts that were being considered they
really understood the challenges that
they were facing and this idea of
collaborating to solve problems is
something that he continues to use as a
pedagogical method now it's not just
something that people used in law school
or in physics Scott Paige who's a
professor of complex problems at the
University of Michigan he has he's done
a number of studies where he finds that
when you have a group of people trying
to figure out what the answer is to a
particular problem there's often a
situation in which some people and
everybody has given to that you can give
to answers and he said you want to have
people who are going to give answers
that are unpredictable and you want to
have people who are looking at the
problem from a very different
perspective because it's through that
collaborative
interaction that you really get to the
heart of the problem that many people
who are looking at the problem see a
problem but they don't necessarily
understand the depth of the problem they
don't necessarily understand what the
problem is connected to but when you
bring people with very different
perspectives into the situation then it
opens up different people's eyes for
example in Scott pages studies he said
that when you're giving somebody a test
and somebody gets seven questions right
but they get three questions wrong and
you might want to put them with somebody
who got six questions right and of the
six questions the three of the ones that
the other person got wrong this person
got right and you want to put people
together who have different perspectives
different strengths and through that
process you get to address a much
greater sense of what the problem is now
why am I talking to you about higher
education and why am I talking about
different ways of solving problems I
think it's really important especially
in the context of this particular
conference that we start thinking about
different ways of solving the problem we
just had a conference discussion this
morning about the Voting Rights Act and
the way in which this particular Supreme
Court has decided that the Voting Rights
Act may still remain on the as part of
legislature that is simply not
legislature than anybody can do anything
with it's just sitting there now it
means we have to learn how to
collaborate with people who disagree
with us we have to learn that it's not
just about competitive individualism
it's not just about trying to show that
you're smarter than everyone else it's
really a an important opportunity for
looking at ways of collaborating with
not
not your opponent per se but with other
people who are looking at the problem
slightly differently than you are but
that different perspective is really
important really helpful if you connect
to it so going back to Scott page he
says if you have people taking a test
and one person got you know seven of the
10 questions right and somebody else got
seven of the questions wrong but the
three questions they got right were the
three questions that the first person
had gotten wrong you still might want to
have that that group work together
because they're they're coming from
different perspectives and as a result
you've covered the area even though the
people that you've brought together are
not equal they're not equivalent in the
sense that one person obviously did
better on the exam but missed issues
that somebody else could help them
understand so I don't want to bore you
with with other examples of
collaborative problem solving but but i
do want to suggest that there are in
terms of diversity there are really
important issues both of gender & of
race in thinking about problem solving
for example i need a woolly who's a
professor at carnegie mellon did a study
where and she did a study with another
professor in which she had people
wearing these big glasses to see where
their eyes were when they were trying to
solve a problem and and what she
discovered is that the more women you
had in the group the better the group
was at solving problems why because the
women actually listened to what everyone
else was saying the men on the other
hand right they were dominating the
conversation that's not to say that they
didn't have something to to a just to
address or two
provide it's that they thought they were
the answer to the to the conversation
they were the leader of the conversation
they were the solver of of of the
problems and what Anita Wooley says in
describing her findings the more women
you had in a group the better the group
was at solving problems up to
eighty-five percent once you had
eighty-five percent women you could then
have some men now that's an interesting
that to me that's a really interesting
idea in that I feel it's time for us and
we were talking a little bit about
what's happened with the Congress it's
time for us to get more women into
positions of power more more people of
color elected to positions of power but
it doesn't mean that they necessarily
have to get elected or necessarily have
to assume positions of power by pursuing
conventional means in other words by
running for office and then trying to
get a position as a member of Congress
or as a member of your legislature and
then once you're in the legislature in
Congress then you start to think you're
really powerful and then you start to
think about ways in which you can remain
powerful and the relationship between
those who represent and those who are
being represented is is not equal so
might the point I'm trying to make
basically is that we have to learn how
to be collaborative in solving problems
rather than dominative or dump
domination ille we have to learn how to
listen to other people with whom we
disagree not because we will then agree
with them but to hear if there are
things that they say that are at least
close enough to to where we want to go
that we can work together in that early
starting in
in that context but the key point that
I'm trying to make is the power of
collaborative problem-solving and the
importance of us learning how to work
with other people especially other
people who have very different
backgrounds very different strengths if
we want to really interrogate and and
really lead and i don't mean lead in
terms of being at the front of the march
I mean influence the way in which we
think about merit the way in which we
think about politics the way in which we
think about leadership and so I want to
end with a story that Nelson Mandela
tells about this concept of leadership
he says that he was influenced by
shepherds in South Africa when he when
he was growing up because if you were a
shepherd and it was time to corral the
flock to go home at night you don't just
stand in front of the flock and say hey
come on let's go you stand behind the
flock you identify one or two of the
young sheep who are moving in the right
direction and then you Corral the rest
of the flock to follow those young sheep
and so in some ways I see you as the
young sheep right and the challenges for
you guys to be moving in the right
direction but to do so with energy and
with a sense of commitment to
collaborative problem-solving thank you
very much
so at this point we're going to have
questions of Professor corner you can
see there are two microphones and we'd
ask that you queue behind the
microphones okay see so one of the
things just I'm happy to do that I just
want to use this as an opportunity to
tell you the way I would do it if we had
more time if we had more time please you
know I was given my instructions I don't
know I just want it this is an
opportunity how would should we do it
what's up how should we do it do you
think I can't hear you how do you how
would you like to do this oh the well
the way I would like to do it is for
people to talk to the other people at
their table so that they have a sense of
whether what they're saying makes sense
or whether what they're saying is
something that's so far a Miss they
shouldn't say it oh you mean before they
ask a question yes oh I don't mean they
should I'm not saying they should get
permission right from their group I
think they should try out the side
really good idea but I'm going anywhere
so can I ask my question yes because you
know even after collaborating those who
know me well know we don't are sitting
at this table would know that I really
wouldn't care and I would just asking
yeah okay so here's here's my question
just this just to start us off I love
this idea about collaborative
decision-making it's interesting though
that the examples that you use are you
know about math and physics you know
places where there wouldn't necessarily
be I say necessarily because this isn't
obviously true ideology but you've
already referenced it in your remarks
about you know a congress that's having
difficulty getting things done getting
things done in part because there's so
much polarization I wonder if you want
to say something about how to think
about if at all maybe you would say
there are limits right that's limit case
how to think about this kind of
collaborative decision-making in a
context of extreme extremely polarized
ideology and you know especially with
reference to the issues that you care
about so deeply well because I know
something about the substance of what
you're saying I would probably be
interested in people who are looking
forward rather than people who are
looking backwards so for me it's not
about replacing or reinstating or saving
the voting rights act as it has been
it's really about using this as an
opportunity to move forward in a new
direction and to think about at least
from my perspective if I were in charge
I would ask people to go around and
interview people from around the world
and ask the people in South Africa
particularly as the people in Germany
how they run their elections the reason
I say Germany is because they run their
elections is because the United States
of America insisted they do it the way
they do it and they do it in a way that
allows them to votes they get to vote
once for the person who's going to
represent them geographically let you
know lives in the community knows the
problems of the community and one that's
idea logical that that represents your
views and that's something the United
States imposed on Germany after World
War two now if the United States thought
it was a good idea after World War two
seems to me we could go back and draw on
that since it seems to have worked right
so so I do think that it's it's an
opportunity to investigate what else is
happening around the world I'd be nice
to look at Australia where you have to
vote and and and think about what's
happening contemporaneously rather than
what the four fathers thought in the
1700s when they all connections at all
when a lot of them had slaves right I
don't know why we've validated them for
you know the last 300 years
I mean obviously they did some good
things but they also did some very bad
things yeah if we had more time you guys
could talk to your neighbors and it
would but we don't have the time so can
I so I'm going to you represent this and
I'm going to assume that my table is on
board with me we that's mine you must be
an American over lunch so they can feel
where I'm come bro so I like this model
and I think it it strikes at the core of
a norm that has the backing of hundreds
of years of you know that is very the
very core of our liberal individualistic
democracy and yet i'm trying to think
about how this plays out when we have
such entrenched segregation across space
that many of us no longer live in the
cross class neighborhoods of yesteryear
many of us literally as i mentioned this
morning seventy percent of us would have
to move to a different place to have
that kind of connection with different
people of different perspectives and
life experiences and so collaboration
might take place but it's going to take
place within the context that we're in
which is highly segregated highly siloed
neighborhood spaces educational spaces
political spaces when you look at maps
of the United States the number of
counties from 1970 to today the number
of counties that are that are now
politically homogenous has increased
rapidly so I guess I'd like a little bit
more specifics about how you see this
can this take place until unless we've
addressed those prior siloed heavily
segregated contexts that many of us find
ourselves in so I think it's a fair
question I think it's
important question and I haven't really
addressed or thought through this issue
in the context of elections I've thought
through it much more in the context of
higher education and so I think if we
think if we consider higher education as
a experiment then and it works assuming
it does then I would move into the
political domain but so when I say in
the educational context what am I
talking about I'm talking about the
posse foundation as an example posse
foundation is an organization that
brings together groups of people who
come from working class or otherwise
challenged backgrounds and they are
admitted or selected to work as a group
of 8 to 10 people and are then eligible
for being admitted to a college based on
their posse so not one person gets
elected but the posse gets selected now
what does what's the significance of
that especially for people who are
coming from working-class families where
they or from families where no one in
their family or certainly not their
parents have gone to college or who are
in many ways not working beyond perhaps
working in an automobile factory or
worse or something like that and the
posi program identifies people who can
work together to contribute something to
the project and can reinforce each other
and remind each other that even when you
are going backwards you still have us to
help you go forwards and I think the
posse program is a really good example
of this notion of collaboration
obviously it's in posse I'm not I'm not
suggesting they do this and they don't
that people go to college and they all
have to
you know do their homework together or
they have to prepare for the same
courses they don't necessarily have to
take the same courses it's the
opportunity to be in an environment in
which other people understand your
challenges and are prepared to give you
the opportunity of complaining and then
reinforcing you it's like if you were
you know playing football or you were
playing basketball and you're working on
a team that the team everybody on the
team doesn't do everything the same but
the team as a team wants people to do
well and that's I think the same idea
impossi that they want people to do well
but not necessarily do exactly what
they're doing either thank you others
I thank you for the talk how do you
collaborate with people who question
your very legitimacy in an institution I
mean it has like obvious ramifications
with politics and the voting rights act
like we've been talking about but in
particular higher education I'm sorry is
there light on me you years yeah cocoa
butter sorry I'm like shine like
Jermaine Jackson not now and it's messed
up I'm real sorry okay so California
raisin right now the question I guess I
have for you is in particular I'm taking
the lsat tomorrow I've been reading a
lot about mismatch theory pressure Rick
sander i believe the general idea see
you you're familiar um the general idea
if those were unfamiliar is that
african-americans display lower
undergraduate GPA s and lower LSAT
scores and they're widening counterparts
and so a new way of looking at furman of
action would be to shunt those students
into second third fourth tier law
schools where they were more likely to
succeed and therefore become lawyers
that's his theory I found a little
repugnant when I was reading about it
when I learned about in an intelligence
squared debates and I like to hear your
view on it because people like that make
assumptions about black intelligence
based on their own and you know
assumptions about where african-american
have been allowed to do well or been
able to effectively you know push
themselves through the ranks and it'll
assume that are things like affirmative
action should no longer exist in the way
they you know currently army if they're
people who agree with us on the Supreme
Court when people are saying they don't
want you in the institution that you're
not smart enough that you're not good
enough no matter what you do you'll
never quite be as good as other members
of the electorate how do you collaborate
with them in the way you described
you don't collaborate with them if
you're talking about the people I think
you're talking about it it's a really
good question and since you are taking
the exam tomorrow I want to reassure you
of a number of things the lsat is a
terrible predictor of performance in law
school terrible predicts fourteen
percent of the variance in first-year
class is fifteen percent of the variance
second year meaning second year
eighty-five percent of the of the lsat
score takers it's not predicting right
so it creates a kind of artificial
intensity for people you know like you
who have the exam tomorrow and you're
really worried about how well you're
going to do and then that worrying it
interferes emotionally with your ability
to do well and I just want to give you
an example of a student of mine who is
brilliant this actually wasn't a student
of mine he was a he did research for me
he was an undergraduate and he he had a
memory that was so complete he could
tell me what page the information that I
was looking for was on not only what
page what line on the page it was
looking for and yet and he took the LSAT
the lsat test the pretest exams and he
did it 30 times and he still didn't do
well on the lsat the guy is brilliant he
did not do well on the lsat and i had to
i mean he he since then in part because
I reassured him that that was no
reflection on him he's gotten a Rhodes
Scholar I mean he's gotten all kinds of
recognition and in fact he's going to be
going to Harvard Law School in the year
so what is that about well it's I think
he's you know really nervous when he's
taking these tests
and that nervousness deflates his
capacity to think in a way that he
normally thinks so it's it's create it
creates this extremely harsh environment
and the reason that all of this bothers
me so much is that when you look at
people's LSAT scores and you look at
their law school grades the lsat is a
weak predictor of those grades that's
what I was saying earlier predicts
fourteen percent of the variance in
first year grades meaning eighty-six
percent of the time it's wrong so we're
using this test that that is not going
to predict your future in substance but
it may predict your future in terms of
the way in which some organizations call
them law schools are still for whatever
reason indebted to or invested in the
lsat as as as a symbol so tomorrow just
go there feeling very powerful thank you
I'll try little late on the gray hair
though hello professor thanks for you
talk in the context of higher education
as as we move or if we move towards more
a more collaborative approach towards
problem solving and thinking about
classes that sort of stuff does that
affect how we assess or how we should
assess individuals coming out of school
so if we talk about grades a grade is or
like a GPA is my individual number but
if it's not tied to my individual
performance is there a better way to
measure group performance or to account
for that somehow ok I'm not sure I'm
following the distinction that you're
trying to make I actually allows
students to take an exam in my lawn
political process class with other
students and I grade the exam the way I
would grade anyone's exam
I don't know who wrote what part of it
but I'm encouraging the students to talk
to each other and I'm assuming the
students at Harvard are not stupid that
they're going to make sure everybody
knows what they're doing they're not
just going to say to somebody go answer
question two and will rely on you and
not check out what you've done so my
effort is to get the students to talk to
each other or my goal and to help those
who are confused to to work it so that
it starts to make sense so that the
students become very good teachers of
each other not just students of me and I
found that to be I mean students can
also just take the the test individually
I'm not insisting anybody work this way
but my my findings are that the students
who worked in groups do much better on
the exam than most of the students who
work by themselves now there are some
students who are just so brilliant that
they don't need any help but they're
rare so so you don't have to change
yourself in other words in order to
succeed but you do have to challenge
what you know you have to challenge some
of the conventional wisdom and and feel
confident about your own that that
actually kind of got it I said I didn't
realize it but that was exactly the
answer that I was looking for oh thanks
you're welcome
this person is leaving oh hello hi thank
you for your talk I'm going to push you
a little bit more to talk about
collaboration when I mean you talk about
collaborative problem-solving right and
on I want us to think about a little bit
about what does it mean if the problem
can't be solved right so with math and
maybe law exams there is an answer there
is a right answer right how do we think
about issues like inequality and racism
right when you know we live in a world
where some people think it's intractable
right how do we solve these problems
that are unsolvable so what else is to
be gained from collaborative work that
isn't coming up with like a solution
what else is to be gained because I
think for some people that's the
challenge right it's like we're not
going to solve the problem of inequality
in my critical race theory class right
but we're doing some kind of
collaborative collaborative work that's
getting us to something right it's a
process so I'm wondering if you could
talk more about that process and the
benefits when there's no I don't want to
say solution but when we may not find a
solution right but there is something
that seems to be gained from doing that
kind of collaborative work so I think
that's a great question and I I think
that the fact of working with other
people and even if you don't come to
quote the right answer or the best
answer that act of working with other
people itself challenges you to think
outside of your own box and it's it's
learning how to listen to other people's
comments to try to incorporate what
they're saying and to to realize that
you know you may have looked at things
with a
tively narrow perspective and you forgot
what was happening on the far right or
the far left and as a result it just
infuses what you're doing with I think
more information they do something in
Sweden that has been imitated in the
United States in Sweden as you know it's
very cold in the winter although I can
tell you in Boston it's really cold
Boston is not Sweden yet but moving in
that direction or i should say cambridge
so in sweden it when it's really cold
they have people read something like
they create little groups it's like a
posse but they're not going to college
they're living in there in their various
homes and they get together in the
evening in in someone's home talking
about what they've all red and people
have very different views but that
process gets them to at least willing to
listen to what somebody else is saying
and hearing what somebody else is saying
for the first time hearing meaning
really incorporating what they're
hearing it I'm not saying they're hard
of hearing and that that process creates
a kind of interaction and then this
group starts to think not just well this
is the book I read or this is the the
article I read but this is a problem
that I've been trying to address in the
way in which the cars are going in front
of my house or you know some concrete
problem and because they've they've
started to see each other as having
different strengths and different
experiences they start to listen to each
other and and they become capable of
thinking together as a group and I don't
mean that they all agree with each other
but they focus on a particular problem
and they represent different aspects of
it and then they get organized and they
go to mass meetings and I would say look
at Taylor branches book on
parting the waters and in particular the
Montgomery bus boycott where you had
black people who had very little power
feeling empowered by going to church for
a mass meeting and the mass meeting was
not there to determine who's the
smartest person in this room and we're
going to send that smartest person out
to go negotiate with the bus company
right that this was a way of giving
people a sense of of identity but also
of connection and feeling really
powerful that that they were part of a
larger group not just having to to make
all of these decisions individually and
independently
discussion and in a collaborative spirit
go forth and solve problems one quick
announcement before we all head out is
we're going back to 77 prospect in the
downstairs for two more panels one on
capital formation within minority
communities and one on punishment and
surveillance and deportation and so
please join us and join us for the
reception afterwards and thank you so
much Lonnie oh well thank you